okay so basically the client called and
he is making a feature and in it he
needs an MRI box so it has a hint of a
sci-fi theme to it but it's still very
grounded very down-to-earth so the
client wanted just a small box very
simple looking but it has to look like a
piece of medical equipment in a sense so
you know very sterile white clean lines
the best way that I thought of doing it
was to create a box and vacuum format so
I could have very smooth rounded edges
and something that looks clean and
simple but still has that element of
something of a piece of equipment you
know you could go to like a thrift store
and probably find a piece of kitchen
equipment or a piece of electronics or
something like that that kind of looks
like something you can kind of convert
it into whatever you want but what the
client wanted was actually very very
simple in a sense it was just a box and
his dimensions he was kind of open to
kind of within that frame of maybe like
eight inches to 12 inches so I can't
revise and just went to ten it had to
have just one function button it was
like a very simple just clean box with a
screen and one function button and that
was that he didn't want any kind of
detailing on it or a logo or anything
that kind of distinguished it it kind of
won everything he kind of wanted it to
have an ambiguity to it that lent it
gave it a bit of a mystery sort of I
didn't want to necessarily pull like an
object off the shelf like an old toaster
or something like that or a little oven
something that was gonna be too
recognizable even if I cleaned it up
right dressed it up and and changed it
enough to where it would look different
I feel like you still would be like oh
you know what that's my
as that toaster in her basement you know
I mean I would rather go with a
completely clean slate and create the
box completely from scratch that being
said I did up some sketches my first
ones were probably a little too
complicated and then I kind of worked
back you did leave you know some
creative license as I come up with some
ideas and show me what you got and I'm
sure you know whatever you come up with
will be cool
so I sent up some sketches and we talked
back and forth and get feedback and
basically this is my last sketch an SD
it's very very simple
it's a lot less complicated this in my
first sketches what I'll do is I'm going
to sculpt the box out of MDF board which
is like a press board basically you can
get very clean cuts out of it and sand
it very smooth and it's pretty easy to
work with so I think that's what we're
gonna do the other thing is then we're
going to like as I said we're gonna use
the vacuform machine now I know you're
probably like I'm a banking floor
machine and how the hell do you build
one well there actually are a lot of
tutorials online and how to build your
own makeshift kind of effective for
machine at home and it's really actually
very simple if you have like a high
power vacuum or a shop vac or something
and you need a heat source the rest of
the stuff you can basically just build
on your own I made you a tutorial in the
future of how I built mine but like I
said there are a lot of tutorials on
YouTube and stuff like that that are
very simple and very easy examples of
how to build a back
machine so we're just gonna measure out
our basic box and cut it out of the MDF
board and then ya go from there now once
I made my measurements and my cuts I
only had to make one side of the box
because I could just vacuum form that
same shape four times and have my four
sides and the bottom was going to be an
extra piece of ABS plastic and the top
was going to be a lens or a piece of
acrylic that the light could shine
through so I double up the two pieces
and rounded off the edges and the
corners get a nice round shape we're
gonna be using as I said ABS plastics
thermoforming plastic there are a couple
different kinds styrene and abs are the
most common and you can get them in
black white or clear obvious we're gonna
use white cuz I want that look this has
got a nice ABS has a little bit of a
glassy or shinier finish and on the
other side has a really kind of rough
texture so this would be the inside of
our form and somebody outside to perform
yeah you just take this my machine is
set up for 24 by 24 sheet you can make a
smaller thermoform machine you know that
does 12 by 12 or 12 by 16 or whatever
you can buy sheets and various diocese
or you can buy them real big and cut
them into whatever customize and you
have however you want
I took near like I build on machine
because I want to do some larger pieces
and smaller pieces so the board actually
comes out and I'm gonna place it with a
smaller one and you can buy sheets then
in either 12 or 24 just easier to cut
them then so I'm just gonna stick this
into my frame
so my frame is basically just that it
says two pieces of plywood that I took
the center out of and then using a
continuous danger of piano hinge on one
end and some fasteners on the sides just
tighten it down and I've got some
weather stripping on the inside of the
frame to kind of hold
plastic into place that's it all right
sir brain Ichigo
got our substrate we got our positive or
the model whatever we're gonna make the
back and form
turn down our heat alright now this is
basically just a garage heater it was
like 50 bucks or something and I created
this box that's lined with aluminum foil
and it's got a little bit of a reducer
to it
because the space heater or the garage
here that I had was like 24 inches by
like 12 inches maybe so I had to kind of
reduce it on either side so it kind of
fans out and then I created this box
it's like an insulated put some
insulation in there so the heat is all
directed down towards our substrate
which abs we're using and I'm using a
1/16 thickness which is get a nice
rigidity to it so it's gonna be a nice
hard plastic it's not too thick to where
we can't get a good mold or a good
vacuum seal over it but it still has a
nice rigidity that will create a nice
hard box if you're going to be doing
that conforming to create like an armor
or something that we want to make storm
trooper or something like that that's
I think there's probably a pretty good
thickness I would say if you know you
might go a little bit thinner it's gonna
be a little bit cheaper if you styrene
that's a little bit cheaper but it's
also it's it's not as sturdy its abs I
don't think so
so we're going to be for this to heat up
it should take about seven eight minutes
for this heat so it kind of depends on
what you're using but then once it heats
up we'll drop it down over our vacuum
box turn on the vacuum it's going to
suck the air out and plataform over our
positive it's just a waiting game down
okay it's got a pretty good sale going
so thing is you don't really too long
and have it burn a hole or melt all
together and fall out to your table
that's not going to be good itself
think we're pretty good
that's it
now I just cut my form out the plastic
using my rotary tool and then sanded the
edges down then once I hit it all sanded
down all the edges are clean I glued the
box together using a two-part epoxy and
it bonds really well the plastics
just curing didn't have to be too clean
on the inside because you're never gonna
see the inside the top is going to have
a clear acrylic lens that the light can
shine through so using a simple socket
it's an extra wire and button that I
have it is wired up using an old
extension cord as my plug
shop light the red bulb from Home Depot
pretty simple
test it out
works
and as I said I used a piece of acrylic
for my lens so you don't want to see the
the light bulb
so use a frosted really
that's completely peace
oh no I'm sure not pretty well the
client was happy
and the footage that you're about to see
is footage that they provided over the
film synthetic love I still haven't seen
the film but basically I think it's like
a dark romantic comedy play with some
kind of sci-fi type element with the
whole like portable MRI machine II
obviously this is a very simplified MRI
machine there is no attempt to make it
literal in the sense that as the be
believable it's just a plot device
all right so here's the completed MRI
box the client said that I actually
didn't have to put a battery in it it
could just plug in so let's simplify
things quite a bit
I had the parts already so it's just
that simple socket you've got your
positive and negative on either side I
got plenty of black and white wire an
extension cord or a piece of cable or
something like that or an old power
cable is something that doesn't work
anymore and just cut it off I keep those
around because you never know when you
might need it so yeah and the switch was
just in a bag full of switches that I
have I collect switches all kinds of
switches when parts and stuff like that
break down or electrical equipment
sometimes I just go and buy switches at
American science and surplus or the
hardware store or something if I see a
cool switch on an old piece of
industrial equipment or something like
that I'll take it off a lot of times
yeah they still work is which is still
good test them but I've had this switch
sit in a bag switches for years and
wanted to have a use for it and I think
they kind of fit this perfectly he
wanted a switch that was very much like
a video game button and I actually have
one but this was that was a little
cooler with the it actually had the
metallic tightening nut on here
I used that metallic tape to cover up my
scenes I know it's pretty cheap trick so
this is it simple completely dimensional
at different phases I want the face of
it to be completely clean I don't want
any Bosman or any raised elements on the
face of it I wanted that to be the most
ambiguous part of the of the piece and
yeah like I said it's very simple just a
simple white box but with rounded edges
and
so it looks pretty clean it's got a nice
gloss to it and yeah lights up your home
in my range